[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHAD TYLER: So with this
session, what we'll do
is we'll talk through
a little bit about how
we think about security
at Google and in G Suite.
And then we will show
you some of the products
that we have that can
remove some of that work
that you're having to do.
And then we will spend
some time in demos.
We'll spend quite a
bit of time in demos
because we think it's helpful
to see how these things work.
And then we'll
finish up by having
one of our partners, Sumo Logic,
talk about their experience
in integrating through our
APIs, and how they are helping
you automate what
you're doing as well.
So with that, security is
increasingly difficult.
There are more and more
attacks, and those attacks
are more and more sophisticated.
So, as administrators
and security staff,
it is something that is
increasingly difficult
to protect your users'
devices and data.
So at G Suite, what
we try to do is
we try to think through how
we can provide you the tools
that you need to really cover
the different threats that
are coming at you, and ensure
that you are best protected
against those.
We've had the chance to
have a lot of conversations
with our customers, partners,
and analysts, and what we see
is reoccurring themes.
There's a lot of
security tools out there
that give you a lot of
data, but at the same time,
they fail to provide really
actionable, valuable insights.
Those that do provide
good insights, many times,
lack the controls
and tools that you
need to go in and
remediate those things
and fix them quickly.
And the solutions that do manage
to provide both of those to you
are, many times, very complex.
They require specific expertise
that are very hard to find,
or a lot of training that
takes a lot of time and energy
and money.
So what we see is we see
a lot of organizations
that have security tools that
are partially implemented,
and they're planning on
continuing to implement
those and finish them.
Or they finish the
implementation,
but they're just not sure
how to effectively leverage
those tools.
So the guiding principle
that we are using at G Suite
is, how can we provide
you a comprehensive set
of tools that is, at the same
time, simple and easy to use?
And so we want to
cover all of your needs
and all of the various threats
that are coming at you,
but at the same
time, we want you
to be able to pick up those
tools and start using them
and start finding value.
And so, over the
last year, you've
seen a lot of launches
coming in security,
and these are just
a few of those.
Things like automatic enrollment
in Google management--
Google device management.
So when a user
comes in with a BYOD
and they sign in with their
corporate credentials,
it's automatically enrolled
for light management.
And that allows you to see
what data those devices
are accessing and exactly
what those devices are doing,
and it also allows you
to wipe corporate data
from those devices.
Security health and the
security dashboards,
which give you a high-level
overview of important security
metrics from your organization.
The Investigation tool, which
allows you to dive in quickly,
get deep in the data, and
take remediative steps.
The Alert Center, where we
communicate the most important
things to you that you should
look into, and proactively
let you know about things
that are happening.
And then, of course, Gmail.
And Gmail, we know, is a
huge vector of attack--
email, in general, I should say.
So we are constantly
investing in Gmail
to ensure that it is very secure
and covering all of your needs,
and making sure that
your users are protected.
We've launched things like
Security Sandbox, Confidential
Mode, and business email
compromise protections.
And so we're consistently adding
more and more tools for you
there so that Gmail is the
best possible solution for you.
However, as we continue to talk
to our customers, one thing
we consistently hear--
and I'm sure you guys
have heard this as well--
is that there's
always too much to do.
There's always that one product,
or that one vector of attack
that you're trying to get to
that you just can't because you
have too much going
on in other areas.
We have yet to talk to a
security team that told us
that they have too much
time on their hands,
or they're too fully staffed.
We haven't seen that yet.
If you do have that
situation, we'd
love to talk to you
about how you got there.
But with this, what
we're trying to do
is find ways that we
can help you automate
security and remove some
of the redundant tasks
that you're doing now that
aren't really adding value,
or aren't requiring all of
the expertise that you have,
so that you can invest that time
and expertise into other areas
that will add more value
to your organization.
And so with that, what
we want to do is we
want to talk through
just a couple of products
that are currently there that
are removing work from you.
And then we want to walk
through a few new products
or enhancements to existing
products that will help you
better automate your workflows.
And then we'll jump
into some demos
to show you how all these
things fit together.
So earlier, I mentioned Gmail.
Now, I really like
this image because I
think it walks you
through, step by step,
what protections are in place.
And whether you're talking about
before an email is even sent,
or when a user receives it and
opens it and clicks on a link,
or even grants a
third-party OAuth token,
you have protections built
in to help you better protect
each of those steps, and
remove some of that manual work
that you'd have to go in and
investigate and remediate
these things.
So Gmail is an area
where you'll continue
to see new innovations, and
even this image doesn't include
everything because
it doesn't have
Security Sandbox, Confidential
mode, or business email
compromise on there,
so there's even more.
And honestly, if
we put everything
that Gmail is doing
on a slide, it
would be much more
than one slide.
The second thing
I want to hit on,
again, is the Google
Device Management
and the automatic enrollment.
And this is something
that has had
a really positive impact for
a lot of the organizations
that we work with.
It gives them logging
and visibility
into what is happening,
and all of those logs
are integrated into many of
our other security products,
like the Security Center.
On top of having visibility of
what these devices are doing,
you also have the option
to wipe that data.
So you don't have to go in and
manage those devices as much
in the case of BYOD devices.
And hijacking prevention is
another area I want to call out
and, specifically, security keys
are a very, very effective way
to protect your users.
And if you can prevent
the hijackings,
that saves you a
ton of work that you
have to do later in
cleaning them up,
and potential damage or
loss of company data.
So we don't know
of a single user
that has been compromised when
they were using security keys.
They're that effective.
And we recommend
every user has them,
or at least privileged
users are using them.
On top of the security keys,
though, we're consistently
investing in models to detect
anomalous behavior from users
so that we can find those and
we can alert you about them.
And so, a lot of
the alerts that you
may have been seeing
in the Alert Center
are actually generated
automatically
by identifying anomalous
behavior that users are doing.
With that, I now want to talk
about some of the newer betas
and launches that
we have coming out
to help you automate
your workflows.
The first is work we've
been doing around data loss
prevention, or DLP.
And what we've been
doing is working
to unify the experience of
creating a Gmail or Drive rule
so that you can create one
single rule to automate
the protection of both
of those products.
In addition, we'll talk through
some of the other things
we've been doing around
visibility to help you better
understand when those
rules are triggering
and what they're doing.
The second is the
investigation tool,
and we'll hit on the new
activity rules, which
allow you to build
rules to automate
actions or alerts based
on specific events that
are happening.
And then the third
is the Alert Center,
and we'll talk about how we are
making updates and continuing
to improve that product
so that you can see
the most relevant alerts first.
So we just want to hit high
level on each of these,
and then we'll show you
how they fit together
and how they work
in the demo flows.
And so first, Data
Loss Prevention.
If you're not familiar
with the product,
basically what it
is is the ability
to create rules
in Gmail and Drive
to detect certain
patterns, whether that's
strings or regex, or using one
of the predefined detectors
to block exfiltration
before it happens,
or also to detect malicious
information before it
comes into your organization.
One of the really cool things
about Data Loss Prevention
is it's built right
into the product,
so it stops things
before they happen.
So it's not something
that happens,
and then DLP goes
in and cleans it up.
It actually prevents
documents from being
shared in the first place.
We'll show you a little bit
more about what that looks like.
But for the updates for
DLP, what we've done
is we've unified the experience
of creating these rules,
but then also, we've
really invested
in logging and visibility around
what these rules are doing.
We've gotten a lot
of feedback that it
would make DLP much
more effective when
you can see exactly when
it triggers, and make sure
that they are tailored
to the exact data you're
trying to detect and
prevent from being shared.
And so we'll walk
you through how
we've integrated those
logs and that visibility
into the Security
Center, and how
you can use that to
look at other data
and figure out what's happening
with your sensitive content.
The second area is
the Security Center.
There's three major components
to the Security Center.
The first is Security
health, which keeps you up
to date on the newest
tools and settings that
are available to you to best
protect your organization.
This is really meant to
help you be proactive
and to prevent issues
before they even happen.
The second is the
Security dashboards,
which give you that high-level
overview of important metrics
in your organization.
These also give you
actionable content
that you can find issues
and then jump quickly
into the Investigation
Tool to act,
so they're meant to
help you detect issues.
Then the Investigation
Tool, which
allows you to do
really advanced queries
to correlate data
across different types,
and then to take
large, bulk actions.
And this, too, is
really powerful
because it scales
from whether you
want to delete one email
from a user's inbox,
or whether you want
to delete a million.
So it scales really well to
the size of your organization.
So with the Security
Center, one of the things
we're really excited about--
and we've been doing a lot of
work on the Security Center,
in general, but
this session we'll
mainly focus on the
new Activity Rules.
And again, these
allow you to, based
on any log query you do
in the Investigation Tool,
create automated
actions and alerts
to let you know when
those things happen.
And so we'll show you
how powerful those
can be in remediating issues
we've seen in the past,
and they work great
as a companion
to Data Loss Prevention rules.
So with that, I want to
welcome my colleague Darshan
on the stage, who will
talk a little bit more
about the Alert Center and
some of the changes we've
been doing there.
DARSHAN PATEL: Thank you, Chad.
My name is Darshan
Patel, and I'm
one of the product managers
within G Suite that
works on Alert Center.
First of all, I'm super
excited to be here
to tell you about
the new beta features
that we're launching in the
Alert Center that has launched
as of this morning.
But first, a little bit of a
summary about the Alert Center.
The Alert Center launched
about six months ago,
and it's available for
all G Suite licenses.
So that includes Basic,
Business, and Enterprise,
and it really provides
three key capabilities.
It provides a
single pane of glass
of all your essential
security notifications.
So this makes it easier
for you to save time
with everything in one place.
It also gives you a view
of your overall security
exposure to help you prioritize
your team's workload,
as well as making
it easy and faster
to do remediation with
integration into other tools.
The Alert Center has
several different types
of alerts across three
primary categories.
The first category is
phishing and malware.
As Chad talked about, that is
one of the most common threats
that we see, and
his slide earlier
showed about 91% of
cybersecurity starts in email.
So this is an area that
we continuously invest in.
So we show that 99.9% of
spam and phishing emails
get stopped before they
make it to the user,
but user attacks keep changing
over time and we keep learning.
As we learn, we go
back and see if any
of the messages inside
your users' inboxes
have been affected and match new
patterns we've learned about,
and this is what we
call Reclassification.
When this occurs, we
will automatically
move the emails from
your users' inboxes
and put them into the
Spam account for you.
And if your users had already
engaged with those messages,
you will get a notification
in the Alert Center
to let you know that
there's something
that you should go
investigate, and then you
can move it or delete
it for your user.
The second category
is Account Warnings,
and this is where we're
using machine learning models
to detect suspicious
behavior that might
be occurring in that account.
This is looking for
compromised accounts that
might have occurred
during login, or even
during in-app activity.
And the third area
is Device Management
that Chad also touched upon.
Here, we're automatically
looking at suspicious device
behavior, so if a
device has been rooted,
or it's jailbroken,
or device properties
have changed on that device.
And one of the key goals of
the Alert Center, for us,
is to help you protect
your users, your devices,
and your data.
Now, listening to
our customers is
one of the most
important things we do,
and it helps us make a
good product even better.
We talked to several
hundred customers
where we received feedback
through surveys, interviews,
and our alpha program.
And I'd like to thank all
those alpha customers--
several are here today--
for their participation
in giving us
feedback across
the whole G Suite
family of security products.
One of the common
themes that we heard
was the need for
collaboration, and this
was to make it easier for teams
to prioritize their workloads.
So with today's beta release,
we focused on these areas.
The first one is being
able to help you prioritize
automatically by giving each
alert type a different severity
setting.
So Google has gone ahead
and mapped the severity
to each of the alerts,
but you, as your admin,
you can change those to
fit your business needs.
The second is the
ability to track status.
So you can now see if alerts
are new, in progress, or closed.
And the third is to manage
workloads by assigning alerts
to different team members.
So this enables faster
prioritization and more
efficient collaboration.
So now, let's take
a look at a demo.
So let me quickly log in.
The first demo I'm
going to show you
is how easy it is to
roll into mobile device
management for your users.
There we go.
All right, so let me go to
Mobile Device Management.
So I'm going to
click on the menu
on the upper left-hand
corner, hit Devices, and go
to Mobile Devices.
Let me log in to
my admin account.
And on my device, I'm going
ahead and just logging
into my corporate email account.
So I need to do a
couple clicks here.
So just like any user,
I'm going to log in.
Here, I just need to agree
to the terms of service,
and it's going to check
against the device policies
that you've set up as an admin.
And I just need to agree to
enroll, so let me do that.
And now here, in
the Admin console,
you will see that there
are about 10 devices,
and this is all live.
I'm going to go
ahead and refresh,
and let's see if we see
the new device enrolled.
So perfect, we see Good
Darshan's Pixel 2 Excel
that has just enrolled, and
now you have the ability
to manage this device.
And this device is
following the policies
that you have already set.
If you wanted, you can click on
the three-dot menu on the end,
and you can see some of the
features, like Wipe the Device
or Delete the Device, available.
So that is showing
you just how easy it
is for a user to
automatically enroll and be
protected on the device front.
Next, we're going to go
into the Alert Center.
So I'm going to click
on that same menu
and go to Security
and Alert Center.
And here, you can see
there's several alerts
that the admins can see.
And we're going to
pick the one that's
Device Compromised, so
let me open that one up.
And now, in this
journey, we're going
to go through and see how
easy it is to triage messages
and prioritize them.
So we can see that this
Android device is rooted
and it belongs to
darshan@dynamic70.
That happens to be the
device I had just enrolled,
and there's different
device properties there.
And as we scroll down, we
can see this new section
called Related Alerts.
So this is one of
the new beta features
that we just launched this
week, and what we're doing here
is we're looking
for other alerts
within the Alert
Center that might
have to do with this incident
to help you triage it better.
So the first one here is
Phishing Message Detected
Post-delivery.
So this looks
pretty interesting.
This is one of the examples we
had talked about earlier, so
let me click on that.
And I can see
Google has detected
one reclassified message
from darshan@my.bigr.name.
So that looks pretty suspicious.
So let's go back to
the other message.
Now we know that we have
a story coming together.
Looking at the
next related alert,
I can see that is
leaked password.
So this is another detection
we do automatically
on your behalf.
We are looking at public sites
where your user's credentials
have been leaked, and when
we find those situations,
we automatically notify you
through the Alert Center
so you can work with your
users to remedy that situation.
Another alert is
government-backed attacks.
So again, we are
automatically detecting
if there might be a
state-sponsored initiative that
is trying to
compromise your users.
So it looks like there's a lot
of serious items going on here,
so let me scroll
back up to the top
and prioritize and
assign this alert.
So I'm going to change
the severity to high
because there's a
lot going on here.
I'm going to change the
status to In Progress
and assign it to
my colleague, Chad.
And it automatically pre-fills
and let me apply that.
So again, just
within a few minutes,
we're able to show how easy
it is to triage and prioritize
an alert.
Next, let's go back to
the Alert Center screen,
and we're going to
pretend that now I'm
Chad, just a little shorter,
and go back in here.
And I see that there's
an alert assigned to me.
We would have also
sent an email to Chad
saying that Darshan the admin
had assigned him an alert.
So I'm going to open
this up, and you
can see in the upper
right-hand corner,
all these fields are there.
Again, these are all
part of the new beta.
And if I scroll to the bottom
in the Alert History area,
you can see a change
log of everything that
has happened with this account.
So teams can collaborate better
and know what has happened.
So let me go back up to the top.
This is where we have the
integrated remediation.
So as an admin, I could go
a couple different ways.
One, I might try to figure
out how this happened,
and we did have some leads
there through the phishing
and leaked password alerts.
And the other one
might be to see,
are there any other
things that might
have happened, such
as data exfiltration,
maybe sharing of
Drive documents?
So let's go and click on
the Investigate alert,
and this is part of the
seamless integration.
And now I'm going to open
up the Investigation Tool.
And in the
Investigation Tool, it
is pre-filling the
characteristics from the alert
into the Query Builder so you
don't have to do any of that.
And if I scroll
to the bottom, you
can see there's that result
for the compromised device.
Now, I'm going to
pivot to see if there
might have been any
data exfiltration that
occurred in Drive.
So by the Device
Owner, I'm going
to click on the three-dot menu.
And you'll see a
whole list of items--
let me scroll down
a little bit--
of different ways you can
pivot on this information,
and I'm going to select
Drive logs, Actor.
And this is the look
where darshan@dynamic70
had done Drive log
events, or used Drive.
And I'm going to
add a condition here
to see if the visibility
has been changed.
And in particular,
we're looking to see
if the visibility changed--
let me pick that condition--
has changed externally.
So we're going to look
to see if anything went
from internal to external,
and I'll scroll down and click
on Search.
It usually just
takes a few seconds.
All right, and as
I scroll down, we
will see that there's
six documents that
have changed in Darshan's
account that have
gone from internal to external.
And looking at the titles,
they look pretty sensitive.
We see org charts for a secret
project, M&A activity, PRDs,
sales projections.
So let's go ahead and
click on the checkbox
to select all of them, and look
at what actions we can perform.
So here, we can
change the owners,
remove users, disable,
download, copy,
print, as well as go a little
deeper with file permissions.
So let's go ahead
and click on that.
And now it's going to
open up a new window where
you can see more details
on exactly who documents
have been shared with.
In this case, we can
see the Project Zero Org
Chart has been shared mainly
with internal employees
at Dynamic 70, but we also see
there is one external person
of Bad darshan@my.bigr.name.
And this one, if you
may recall, happened
to be the same related
alert that was responsible
for the phishing email.
So let me go ahead
and revoke privileges
by clicking on the menu,
and I can remove access
for Bad Darshan.
But we also want to look
at all the documents,
so let me click on the left side
to select all the documents.
And I can click
on Actions, and I
can go ahead and select
which users I want to remove.
And I am going to remove
darshan@my.bigr.name.
And now he has been removed from
access for all of these files.
While we're on the
screen, we should also
go and check to see
if any documents might
have been shared publicly.
So I'm clicking on
links up at the top,
and I can see three
of the documents
have been made public.
So let's go ahead and click on
the title, select all of those,
and edit the link sharing.
And let's make these
all restricted.
And I'm going to go
ahead and apply that.
All right, so just
within a few minutes,
we're able to go through three
common security use cases where
we can show how we help automate
and simplify the experience.
The first one was
automatic enrollment
into mobile device management.
The second one was
automatically looking
for incidents and
suspicious behaviors that
are occurring for your users.
In this case, it was the
device being compromised.
We also saw a leaked password
and a post-delivery phishing
reclassification,
as well as how easy
it is to triage, investigate,
and remediate a situation.
With that, I'm going
to hand it back over
to Chad to continue
on with the demo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHAD TYLER: So really quick,
let me set this up here.
OK, so Darshan
walked us through how
you can use the Alert
Center to better understand
the threats that are coming
into your organization,
and then how you can quickly
use those to remediate issues.
I want to talk a
little bit about how
we can use policy to prevent
issues from happening.
And then also, after we've
done an investigation
similar to what Darshan showed
you, how we can set an activity
rule to prevent that type of
thing from happening again,
or at least automate
alerts around those.
And so, what we're
going to do is
we're going to start with
the new Data Loss Prevention
experience.
If you come to the left-hand
menu and you go to Security
and you look under
data Protection,
this is the beta experience.
So if you sign up
for the beta for DLP,
this is what you'd see.
So here, we can click
on Manage Rules,
and we have a list of
rules we've created.
And in this specific
scenario, we
have a rule we created
around Project Utopia, which
is a sensitive project that
this company, this organization,
is working on.
And so what they've done
is they've gone through
and they've created a policy
for the entire organization.
When a file is shared,
or we could do also
when an email is sent,
if it contains Utopia,
we want to block
external sharing.
And so we've created this rule.
And now, if we go to
Drive, we can find
a file related to Utopia here.
So if we open something
related to Utopia,
what we see as an end user is
it actually changes the way
that the sharing icon looks.
So it shows a shield, showing
that this document is actually
sensitive, it should not
be shared externally.
If the user hovers
over the sharing icon,
it also informs them of that.
And this is really
important because it
is educating the end users.
It's helping them understand
what types of content
are sensitive and
what they should
be thinking about when they're
looking at documents like this.
If they do decide to go ahead
and continue and try to share
this document, when they go to
share it to anyone on the web,
what will happen is they'll
actually receive an error which
will tell them that
this is sensitive,
they cannot share it externally.
Beyond just educating
the end user,
though, we know that it's
really important for admins
to have visibility into how
their policies are interacting
with content and exactly
what's happening.
So one of the other
things that you'll
see in the beta
experience for DLP
is you'll see this
Investigate Rule option.
This is similar to what
Darshan was showing you
in the Alert Center.
But when you click
on this, what happens
is it takes you into
the Investigation Tool
and it queries for that specific
rule, which will show you
all of the logs associated
with it for when that rule has
triggered.
So we can see that,
specifically, this rule
has triggered on quite a few
different documents related
to Utopia, so the
roadmap, the financials,
the competitive analysis.
And it looks like it's all been
done by this Chad Tyler user.
So there might be something
going on with this user.
We can dig in
deeper and actually
figure out what's happening.
So we can dig in and
remediate this specific issue.
So we'll pivot on this user, and
we'll look at Gmail log events
where this user
received the email.
And we'll say,
specifically, we want
to see emails that are not
from our current organization.
So we'll copy that.
And also, we want
to filter out emails
that are from Google and
that we don't want to see
the alerts that are coming in.
And then when we query for
that, what this will show
us is the external emails
that this user received.
So we want to see potentially
how this user was compromised
by a phishing email.
So we see several different
emails that came in.
Specifically, we can look at the
log events for what happened.
It looks like this user
only opened and clicked
on one email.
So you can see here the
updated Terms of Service.
They received it,
they opened it,
and then they clicked
on a link, and it
looks like it went
to a malicious site.
So we know that this
might be potentially
how they were compromised.
Now, what we can do
here is we can actually
pivot on this message ID,
and we can see everyone
in our organization
who received this.
And so we'll look for everyone
in our organization who
received this specific email to
make sure that no one else was
compromised.
And so we can see here, quite
a few of our users received it,
but this user was the
only one that opened it
and the only one that
clicked on the link.
Just to make sure that there's
no more issues with this email,
we can come and we can delete
these messages to make sure
that none of our other
users click on this.
So we'll type that in
and we can click Delete.
So now what we can do is--
we've come in, we've
created the DLP rule.
We've looked at where
that's triggered,
and then we've gone to better
understand how that user was
compromised in the first place.
But it looks like this
domain, ink42.com,
is targeting our users.
So we might want
to actually prevent
this from happening
again in the future.
What I want to
show you now is how
you can use the new
Activity Rules that we've
added to the Investigation
Tool to create policies
based on the attributes of
logs that you're receiving.
So we'll create a new query and
we'll say, Gmail log events.
If it's from and it contains
Ink42, we want to block it.
And so we'll say,
specifically, when
we receive emails from Ink42.
And then what we can do, right
within the Investigation Tool,
is we can come to
this three-dot menu
and we can go to Create Rule.
And that takes us to a
pretty similar experience
to what you saw for Data
Loss Prevention, or DLP.
And we can say,
block bad domain.
And then this pulls in
the query that we're
using in the
Investigation Tool itself.
And then when we go
to the next step,
this will generate
a preview for us
for how often emails
from Ink42 have
come into our organization.
So you can see the history
of when that's happened.
And then we can say
if, within an hour,
it happens even zero times--
or if we want to set
a specific threshold,
we can say more than
100 or more than 1,000.
So this works really
well for things
like document exfiltration.
If you want to see if more than
a certain amount of documents
are shared outside
of your organization,
this is a really flexible
tool that you can use.
Then we can set
an action and say,
if we receive an
email from Ink42,
I want to send it
to quarantine or I
want to delete it,
whatever makes sense.
And then, we also want
to receive an alert,
and I want to send that
alert to the admin.
Just that quickly, we
can create a new rule,
which will then perform
that action whenever
our threshold is triggered.
And it will also
send us an alert,
and you'll receive that alert
in the same Alert Center
that Darshan was walking
you through before.
And so that's a
quick view of how
you can use Data Loss
Prevention to prevent things
before they even happen.
How you can use
the logs associated
with those to dig in,
detect, and remediate issues.
And then how you can
go back to prevention.
You can use the Activity Rules
within the Investigation Tool
to use the same queries you
were using to prevent this
from happening again, and
follow that loop of continuing
to tailor your organization
so that you have less
of these things
happening and you
can prevent them from
happening in the first place.
So with that, we
want to jump back
to the slides really quick,
and I want to hit on APIs.
So APIs are obviously
a really important part
of automating security.
All of the data that
we just showed you
is available through these
three different APIs.
And so the product
APIs themselves,
you use the Gmail, Drive,
Device Management APIs,
and you can get the
state information
that we were showing you.
The Reports APIs is where all
of the logs are available.
And then the Alert
Center API allows
you to pull all of the
alerts into other tools
if you're using other
tools to manage your alerts
and to coordinate
your remediation.
And so, we know that the APIs
are a very important part
of this story.
One of the things
that we wanted to do
is show you how
one of our partners
was able to leverage these
APIs to build a product that
allows you to get
better visibility
and automate
remediation as well.
And we also know that
it's very important
to be able to extend this to
your broader ecosystem, which
is why we wanted to bring
Rishi from Sumo Logic
to talk a little bit more
about their experience
in building out a product
based on these APIs.
Rishi.
HRISHIKESH DIVATE:
Thank you, Chad.
So my name is Rishi Divate.
I'm the product manager for apps
and integration at Sumo Logic,
and I want to thank
Google for giving us
this opportunity to
partner with them,
and allowing us to showcase
our integration with G
Suite and Alert Center.
So a little bit
about Sumo Logic.
We are a cloud-native machine
data analytics service
and we support over
2,000 customers
across various
industry verticals.
Some of our key customers are
Airbnb, Major League Baseball,
New York Life, Visa,
and Salesforce.com.
Sumo Logic helps in
three major areas,
the first being
operational analytics,
where we help you
monitor, alert,
and troubleshoot your
application issues
or performance.
The second area is
business analytics,
where we have to
understand how customers
are using your applications.
And finally, security analytics,
which is the focus of today's
presentation, where we help you
monitor, detect, investigate,
and respond to security
alerts and threats.
Sumo Logic provides these
capabilities in one platform
so you get the data at once, and
you get operational, business,
and security insights.
So how does this work?
We collect, index, and
store machine data,
which includes events,
logs, and metrics
from a number of
on-premise, SaaS,
and cloud platform data sources.
Once this data is in, you can
query it with our rich query
language, dashboards, or use
out-of-the-box applications.
So one of these apps is
the Sumo Logic G Suite app.
We have over 100 customers
using this app across the globe,
and it's focused on
three major use cases.
The first being G
Suite usage, and then
administrative activity,
and security monitoring.
So over the past
few months, we've
been working with
the Alert Center team
towards collecting and
analyzing Alert Center data.
So combining Alert Center
data with G Suite activity
logs that we are
already collecting,
and data from other applications
and security data sources,
we see Sumo Logic and Google
providing three key benefits.
The first being the ability
to monitor and detect
critical security threats
by combining alerts
from Alert Center with alerts
from other security data
sources.
Secondly, investigating
and correlating
alerts with G Suite activity
and other applications.
This is so you can determine
the root cause and effects
of your alerts.
And finally, responding
and remediating
alerts when they occur again.
So to summarize
how this works, we
collect data from G
Suite via the Reports API
and from Alert Center
via the Alert Center API.
So these are the APIs that
Chad just talked about,
and I just wanted to commend
the G Suite team for making
this critical data available.
And as we'll see
going forward, this
helps our customers quickly
investigate and respond
to alerts in their
IT infrastructure.
So once this data
comes in, we have rich,
out-of-the-box dashboards that
analyze more G Suite activity
and data from Alert Center.
So let's take a look
at an example of how
Sumo Logic can help
monitor, detect,
and investigate threats.
So this is our G Suite
overview dashboard
that shows a summary of
all the activity that's
happening in G Suite.
And we have drilldowns
specific to Alert Center.
This shows Alert Center
Overview dashboard
that shows all the data that
we've gotten from Alert Center
so far.
So here, we see an example
of a user's credentials
being compromised.
And I just want to point out
the level of detail that's
coming in from
Alert Center, where
you have the username, the
time this compromise happened,
and the alert type.
And this is something
that you definitely want
to go ahead and investigate.
So this brings us to the Alert
Center investigations dashboard
in Sumo Logic, where we've
automatically correlated Alert
Center data with all
of G Suite activity,
and we have these two panels
that show all the G Suite
activities by compromised users.
Similarly, you also want
to look into all the logins
by compromised users to
determine how active they are
and where they're coming from.
This kind of ability,
where we focus
our panels on all activities and
logins by compromised users--
we also have panels for
compromised devices--
we've seen helps security
analysts and security
teams cut down the amount of
time required to investigate
an alert or incident.
So we've talked about
correlating Alert Center
data with G Suite activity, but
what about your other business
applications?
So here, we are
seeing an example
on the right where we are
doing a search in Sumo Logic
across all of
Salesforce.com event data
to get a list of all the reports
downloaded by a compromised
user that was detected
by Alert Center.
So having this capability
of investigating data
across various
applications is something
that is super valuable
for our customers,
and that's why they use us
for their security use cases.
I also wanted to point
out that you can easily
create your own
dashboards in Sumo Logic
by combining dashboard
panels from various apps,
or even creating
some of your own.
So by doing this, you can
create a dashboard that's
very specific to your
company or organization,
and you get a quick overview
of all the security aspects,
whether it's endpoints,
network identity management
systems, cloud platforms, or
even on-premise data sources.
So now that we've looked
into how to monitor, detect,
and investigate
security alerts, let's
talk about how to
automatically remediate these
when they happen again.
So this is a document
from the G Suite Help
that talks about how to identify
and secure compromised G Suite
accounts.
So this is a four-step
process, and this
is an example of a workflow.
Creating and managing
these workflows
in a consistent manner is
critical for maintaining
your overall security posture.
What we, at Sumo Logic,
do is help automate
the creation of these
incident response
workflows by sending data
to a number of ticketing
notification and
response systems.
We also see that this
kind of workflow creation,
and sending critical
data about what happened,
helps in reducing the
time to investigate
by providing context around
an alert or incident.
So for example, listing
out all the activities
that happened by a
particular compromised user.
Finally, creating
these workflows
is also something
that we've seen
that helps prevent alert
fatigue by sending data
to the right teams that
have specific areas
of responsibility,
as opposed to sending
all alerts to the
entire security team.
So just to summarize our
experience as a partner,
we've seen how G Suite and
Alert Center have given us
critical data to further
enable our customers
to monitor, detect, investigate,
and respond to security alerts
and threats.
With that, I'd like
to call Darshan back
on stage to summarize our talk.
[APPLAUSE]
DARSHAN PATEL: Thank you Rishi.
I really appreciate
the great overview
of how Google and Sumo
Logic can work together
to provide integrated
solutions that
fit well into your
existing infrastructure.
To summarize what we covered
today, the first one was--
which Chad had been
talking about--
some of the pain points
that many of you face.
Too much data, lack
of insights, lack
of control, as
well as complexity
with existing solutions.
So we covered three ways.
One is through hijacking
protection with security keys.
Another one is device
management, as well as
phishing protection.
As well, we covered
three of the new betas
that we're launching this week.
First one was the
Alert Center that
now provides built-in
collaboration
to help you prioritize
your alert management.
The second one was
DLP to provide you
capabilities to prevent
sensitive data transfer.
And the third was
Activity Rules that
now helps you automate
repetitive tasks,
as well as apply automatic
actions and alerts.
Also, we want to thank
Sumo Logic for being here
to talk about how we're
collaborating with our partner
ecosystem to build
solutions that
integrate within your
existing infrastructure.
With that, I'd like to thank
all of you for attending today.
At the bottom, there
is a blog that we just
published this morning
that has the link to all
of the beta sign-up
forms for the three
that we talked about today.
And we're going to
stay around afterwards
to answer any questions.
We'll be up front, and then
in the hallway afterwards.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]